hey 42 here every year 10 million
Americans and 275,000 Britons
mysteriously go missing but can someone
literally vanish into thin air
science tells us no but there have been
many stories that say overwise one of
the most bizarre of these is the legend
of David lang David lang gun his family
lived on a farm near Gallatin Tennessee
in the United States in September 1880
David Lang's two children Sarah and
George were playing in the front yard of
their family home their parents David
and Emma came out of the house into the
garden
David headed off into the fields towards
his horses at the same time a buggy
carrying August Peck was approaching a
friend of the family David turned to
walk back to the house and wave to
DeGeorge
a few seconds later in clear view of his
entire family under the Judge David Lang
disappeared in mid-step Emma screamed
and everyone rushed towards the spot
thinking he had fallen into a hole but
there was no hole they searched
everywhere but David wasn't to be found
a few months later the children noticed
a spot where their father had vanished
turned yellow and wilted in a circle 4.6
meters in diameter
several months later Lang's children
heard their father's voice calling out
for help as they played near the spot
but eventually his voice faded away and
they never heard it again from humble
farmers to Lourdes Richard John Bingham
the 7th earl of lucan popularly known as
Lord Lucan disappeared without a trace
on the 8th of November 1974 after he
murdered his children's nanny in the
basement of the Lukens family home in
London by bludgeoning her to death he
fled and was never seen again
the authorities believed he drowned
himself in the English Channel however
there have been numerous sightings of
him
the world mainly in Africa an
ex-detective donkey McLoughlin says he's
collected sufficient evidence to prove
that Lord Lucan in fact fled to Goa in
western India
a former drug dealer named mark winch
handed photograph to the ex detective of
an elderly man taken in 1991 that showed
an unmistakable likeness to Lord Lucan
mark whinge also explained to the
detective how he had become friendly
with the man in the photographs whilst
in Goa he said how the man was a
well-spoken gambler who loved to play
backgammon a game which Lord Lucan was
famous for a single disappearance not
enough for you how about the
disappearance of an entire army
battalion in 1950 during world war one
three members of a New Zealand field
company said they watched from a clear
vantage point as a large battalion of
the Norfolk regiment marched up a
hillside in Silla Bay Turkey the hill
was shrouded by a low-lying cloud
nevertheless the soldiers marched into
the cloud without hesitation they never
came out when the war ended presuming
the battalion had been captured and held
prisoner
the British government demanded that
turkey return them however the Turks
insisted the soldiers hadn't been
captured and they had never so much as
made contact with the battalion if a
whole battalion isn't enough for you how
about an entire village of 2,000 people
disappearing into thin air
in November 1930 a fur trapper named Joe
LaBelle traveled to an Eskimo village on
the shores of lake anjikuni in northern
Canada Joe was very familiar with the
village he knew it had a thriving
fishing community of about 2,000
residents however this time when he
arrived the village was completely
deserted he found one fire still ablaze
on which there was a pot of blackened
stew when the authorities investigated
their findings were rather disturbing no
footprints of any of the residents were
found how did they vacate the village
without leaving footprints all of the
Eskimo sled
were found buried under a 12-foot
snowdrift
they had all starved to death all of the
residents food and provisions were found
undisturbed in their Hut as if nothing
had happened but there was one last
terrifically unnerving discovery all the
Eskimos ancestral graves had been
emptied
creepy stuff but just a spine-tingling
is the mysterious Stonehenge
disappearance in August 1971 one night a
group of hippies decided to pitch tents
in the center of the stone circle and
spend the night
they built a campfire and smoked a few
drinks of weed at 2:00 a.m. a powerful
thunderstorm quickly encroached upon the
Salisbury Plain home to Stonehenge
lightning ravaged the area two witnesses
a policeman and the farmer reported that
the stone to the ancient monument lit up
with an eerie blue light that was so
intense they had to avert their eyes
they heard screams from the campers and
the two onlookers rush to the scene
expecting to find injured bodies but
they found no one the hippies had
vanished all that remained were several
smoldering temples underground out
campfire thanks for watching until next
time